local now bus drivers calling for safety
some even saying they wouldn't take a
ride thank you for joining us on 8 news
now at 4 I'm Brian Loftus I'm Kirsten
Joyce those drivers calling for change
before the board that controls the RTC
eight news now investigator David charns
now with their fleas
bus drivers tell me they feel like
they're not being listened to after
several high-profile incidents on their
buses but the committee overseeing RTC
says their hands are tied I'm hoping to
hear that they're going to get security
for us better security that can protect
us and help us when we're out there
right now we have nothing Sandra Adams
is Vice President of the Union
representing more than 1 000 coach
operators across the Las Vegas Valley if
you were a person who needed to take the
bus would you feel safe no I definitely
would not I would Uber
you would Uber you wouldn't even take
the bus I wouldn't even take the bus I
would Uber after a murder several
stabbings even a person accused of
stealing a bus these drivers came to
this ROTC board meeting pushing once
again for a Transit Police Department
given the fact that my colleague got
stabbed
three weeks ago and and still not out of
trouble
um it's just unacceptable local police
responding to more than 2 000 incidents
on RTC buses last year that's one every
four hours there are more than 200
security guards on some buses but
drivers say they don't do enough RTC
Deputy CEO Francis Julian one incident
is always one too many and just like all
the other Transit agencies uh in the U.S
we've seen a spike
an incident just we're basically a
microcosmos of what's happening in in
the the community are these buses safe
we provided 41 million rides last year
so when you look at the number of
incidents versus the ride bus is quite
safe we're simply telling you
board members say state law prevents
them from starting a Transit Police
Department the board including Las Vegas
mayor Carolyn Goodman saying take it up
with State lawmakers if the statues say
you can't have Transit Police come on
now you guys are in this you you
understand it could be amended revised
it could catch up with the time
it is extremely unlikely Anything could
happen with Transit Police this
legislative session as there were just
three weeks left for lawmakers in Carson
City outside the Clark County Government
Center I'm David charns 8 News Now
and we reached out to Governor Joe
Lombardo's office to see if he would
support a measure to change the law to
allow Transit Police and if he would do
it in a special session we have not yet
received a response